on my orders the united states military
has begun strikes
against al-qaeda terrorist training
camps and military installations of the
taliban regime in afghanistan
air strikes and a promise from a
president to use
force with deliberate purpose these
carefully targeted actions are designed
to disrupt the use of afghanistan
as a terrorist base of operations
the allies military aims in afghanistan
were at first
clearly prescribed destroy al qaeda and
render the taliban
unable to help it the military action we
are taking
will be targeted against places we know
to be involved in the al-qaeda network
of terror
or against the military apparatus of the
taliban
but then the mission morphed expanding
into what sounded like nation building
we know that true peace will only be
achieved when we give the afghan people
the means to achieve
their own aspirations whatever that
meant
the allies would spend another two
decades and two trillion dollars
trying to achieve it john negroponte was
u.s
ambassador to the un at the time having
clearly defined objectives at the
before you enter into a conflict i think
always carries
with it substantial risks but in terms
of what happened in afghanistan was it a
mistake
to take on nation building to expand
that mission outwards it certainly
it was a risky proposition
and uh uh you could call it a mistake
but it wasn't just mission creep a huge
distraction was coming
that would undo the chances of success
general sir robert frye
commanded the royal marines in
afghanistan i think there was an
opportunity
fleeting and squandered but there was an
opportunity which had it been properly
exploited could have perhaps have
created a lasting solution or if that
was too much to hope
at least given the afghans themselves a
fighting chance to sort themselves out
the reason it went wrong was iraq
of the labour cabinet who voted for
military action in 2001
only one would talk about it now claire
short
unsparing in her assessment of the
west's achievement in the decades that
followed
it's a failure i mean it's it's at a
terrible cost in human life and masses
of money spent
that hasn't brought a beneficial outcome
for the people of afghanistan
and it's a humiliation for nato i mean
it really is
the taliban beat nato more than 450
british lives have been lost in
afghanistan
more than 2 000 american tens of
thousands of afghan civilians have died
the cost has been put at something over
two and a quarter trillion dollars
if as seems more than possible the
taliban can now sweep back to power
what was all that sacrifice for
afghan forces must rely on themselves
now and their training
the true test has yet to come if they
fail to hold back the taliban
the west's adventure in afghanistan is
doomed to spectacular
and costly failure dominic waghorn
sky news